N
2032, A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE --
20322 -- SIGNIFICANT INCREASE
FROM LAST YEAR.
FORMER BORDER SECURITY SECTION
CHIEF JOINS US NOW TO REACT.
GOOD MORNING, LACEY.
>> GOOD MORNING.
JOEY: SO IS THERE A SPECIFIC
REASON THAT THEY'RE COMING
ACROSS UNACCOMPANIED?
WHAT'S THE STORY BEHIND THIS?
WHY ARE THESE KIDS COMING HERE
UNACCOMPANIED?
>> WELL, LISTEN, A STORY BEHIND
EACH OF THOSE CHILDREN, AND NOT
EVERYONE COMES HERE FOR THE SAME
REASON.
BUT I DO WANT TO POINT OUT THAT,
YOU KNOW WITH, UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS DOES NOT MEAN AN ORPHAN.
I THINK SOMETIMES WE HEAR THAT
PHRASE AND WE THINK THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE A PARENT BACK HOME,
BUT A LOT OF THESE KIDS ARE SENT
BY THEIR PARENTS TO THE BORDER
TO CROSS WITHOUT A LEGAL
GUARDIANING WITH THEM, AND
SOMETIMES THE PARENT IS STUCK ON
THE MEXICAN SIDE AND THEY SEND
THEIR KID THROUGH BECAUSE THEY
THINK THAT THEIR KIDS CAN GET
ACCESS TO THE UNITED STATES
EASIER THAN THEY CAN.
SO THESE ARE NOT ORPHANED
CHILDREN THAT ARE LIVING ON THE
STREETS, THEY'RE CHILDREN WHOSE
PARENTS OR GUARDIANS HAVE
DECIDED THAT THE IN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES WARRANT WITH THEM
SENDING THEM THROUGH TERRIBLE
CIRCUMSTANCES, ACTUALLY,
TERRIBLE CIRCUMSTANCES TO GET TO
THE BORDER.
JOEY: YOU KNOW, IF THESE KIDS
COME ACROSS UNACCOMPANIED, YOU
HAVE A CHANCE TO FIND PARENTS
HERE IN THE STATES, ARE THEY
SUBJECT TO PROSECUTION FOR
BOOMING -- ABANDONING THEIR
CHILD?
ANYTHING THAT WOULD DETER IN OUR
LEGAL SYSTEM, THAT WOULD PUNISH
AND DETER THEM FROM ALLOWING
THEIR CHILD TO GO ON IN THIS
DANGEROUS JOURNEY?
>> NO.
IF THE PARENT IS HERE WITH
LAWFUL STATUS HERE AND THEY
REQUESTED THEIR KID BE BROUGHT
HERE, THEN THEY'RE NOT CHARGED
WITH ANY SORT OF CHILD
ABANDONMENT.
BUT I TELL YOU, THERE SHOULD BE
SOME CRIMINAL PROSECUTION FOR
THE SMUGGLERS AND THE CARTELS TO
BRING THE KIDS HERE.
YOU KNOW, CARTELS MAKE TERRIBLE
BABYSITTERS, AND THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT THEY'RE TASKED TO DO WHEN
THEY BRING A KID HERE WITHOUT
ANY PARENTS OR GUARDIAN TO TAKE
CARE OF THEM, THEN THE CARTELS
ARE IN CHARGE.
AND WE KNOW CHILDREN SUFFER
SEXUAL ABUSES AND PHYSICAL
ABUSES ALONG THE WAY WHEN
THEY'RE JUST PUT IN THE HANDS OF
THESE TERRIBLE BAD ACTORS.
JOEY: YOU'RE RUNNING FOR ARIZONA
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
AREN'T THERE LAWS AVAILABLE TO
YOU, STATE LAWS?
WHAT DO YOU THINK YOU CAN DO AS
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO HELP AT
LEAST ARIZONA WITH THE BORDER
PATROLS?
>> YEAH, ABSOLUTELY.
THE ARIZONA LAW ALLOWS FOR THE
PROSECUTION OF THE DRUG CRIMES
AT THE BORDER.
WE MOW THAT THE MOVEMENT OF
DRUGS AND HUMANS ARE DONE IN
CONCERT BY THE CARTELS, SO THE
PROSECUTION SIDE OF THE HOUSE TO
TAKE DOWN THE CARTELS.
AND, YOU KNOW, HUMAN TRAFFICKING
IS HUGE.
SOME OF THESE FOLKS BROUGHT
ACROSS THE BORDER, INCLUDING
CHILDREN, ARE BROUGHT HERE FOR
SEX TRAFFICKING AND AND LABOR
TRAFFICKING, NOT JUST BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO MAKE A BETTER LIFE
HERE.
IT'S TERRIBLE WHAT'S HAPPENING
AT THE BORDER, AND THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL CAN WEIGH IN BY HELPING
TO PROSECUTE A LOT OF THE CRIMES
THAT ARE HAPPENING IN CONCERT
WITH THE MOVEMENT OF HUMANS.
JOEY: LACEY COOPER, CANDIDATE
FOR ARIZONA ATTORNEY GENERAL,
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING US
AND GOOD LUCK.
>> THANK YOU.
JOEY: ALL RIGHT.
STILL AHEAD, IT'S NOT JUST
HISPANIC VOTERS WHO ARE TURNING
OUT ON THE DEMOCRATIC -- WHO ARE
TURNING ON THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.